casi siempre zonas están durmiendo
cuando el deslizamiento de tierra se
produjo derribando una ladera en esta
granja orgánica con instalaciones para
acampar los que sobrevivieron fue porque
se despertaron por el ruido de la
catástrofe
estábamos durmiendo y de repente se
escuchó una voz enorme
entonces llegó el deslizamiento de
tierra logramos escaparnos y rescatar a
nuestros amigos y gracias a Dios
sobrevivimos
vemos que la carpa que está a nuestro
lado desapareció por completo nada no
podíamos hacer nada
los deslizamientos de tierra son
habituales en Malasia tras las lluvias
torrenciales que son regulares a finales
de año sin embargo no se registraron
Fuertes lluvias durante la noche en esta
zona mientras los equipos de rescate
siguen rastreando el espesólogo y los
árboles derribados en busca de las
personas aún desaparecidas otro reto es
ahora asegurar los sitios alrededor
he dado instrucciones a los 55 consejos
locales para que comprueben y desalojen
todos los campamentos a lo largo y
alrededor de la zona de alto riesgo
se lo angora es el estado más próspero
del país y ya ha sufrido deslizamientos
de tierra con anterioridad a menudo
atribuidos a la tala de bosques y el
desmonte de cultivos para sembrar unos
nuevos previamente el director de
departamento de incendios había
advertido a los ciudadanos y las
autoridades municipales que paralizan
las actividades recreativas en áreas de
riesgo como las montañas Colinas ríos y
playas debido a la posibilidad de
accidente durante la actual época de
Monzón